ein riesiger betonwall eingekeilt
zwischen zwei mächtigen bergen
ein so eindrucksvoller bau in der
landschaft ist ein meisterwerk der
ingenieurskunst
[Musik]
fünf gewaltige und bauten die verlassen
da stehen
es gibt keine ecken in denen man sich
verstecken könnte ein rettungs tunnel in
den usa zur flucht vor einem nuklearen
madonna
kann sich vorstellen die panische
menschen hier durchströmen aus angst vor
einer atomexplosion
[Musik]
und ein kaum beachteter held des zweiten
weltkriegs
[Applaus]
es ist von kaum vorstellbarer
historischer bedeutung
[Applaus]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauwerken ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
diese anlagen aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht
aber wer hat sie erschaffen und mini und
warum wurden sie wieder aufgegeben
[Musik]
im norden italiens in der gebirgigen
provinz belluno rund 100 kilometer von
venedig entfernt steht ein gewaltiges
meisterwerk der ingenieurskunst
über der stadt long gar ohne ragt ein
mehr als 260 meter hohe beton war empor
der sich zwischen den baum bewachsenen
felsen an den seiten dieser engen
schlucht erstreckt der variant staudamm
[Applaus]
plötzlich sieht man diese riesige
betonwand vor sich auf fragen
[Musik]
das ist wirklich ein beeindruckendes
bauwerk selbst nach heutigen maßstäben
der damm ist immer noch einer der
höchsten der welt
an der oberkante misst der staudamm über
190 meter nach unten hin verjüngt er
sich auf nur noch 27 hier ist derweil
enorme 22 meter dicke über 35 millionen
kubikmeter beton waren nötig um diese
festungsmauer zu errichten heute steht
sie kein wasser mehr sondern über 250
millionen kubikmeter sediment gestein
und geröll
wenn man zu ihren füßen steht fühlt man
sich winzig aber
warum errichteten die ingenieure dieses
gewaltige bauwerk an einer so gewagten
stelle und warum ist es nicht mehr in
betrieb
am ende des zweiten weltkriegs liegt die
ehemalige achsen macht italien dann
wieder das land muss neu aufgebaut
werden dabei spielt das industrielle
kern land im nordosten eine
entscheidende rolle aber die fabriken in
der region leiden unter chronischer
stromknappheit
in den 50er jahren erholte sich italien
noch vom zweiten weltkrieg die
wirtschaft nahm erst langsam wieder
fahrt auf
um den aufschwung anzukurbeln
verschreibt sich das land einem
gewaltigen industrialisierungsprozess
unterstützt von den usa die italien als
wichtigen partner gegen die
kommunistische bedrohung aus dem osten
sehen ein kernpunkt des programms ist
elektrizität aus wasserkraft natürliche
ressourcen gibt es reichlich in den
italienischen alpen zahlreiche flüsse
enge schluchten und regelmäßige
niederschläge bieten perfekte
bedingungen für wasserkraftwerke
wasserkraft zu nutzen bietet sich in den
bergen an denn in engen tälern kann man
das wasser gut aufstauen und es dann
bergab fließen lassen um so strom zu
erzeugen
[Musik]
ingenieure machen das tiefe enge bayon
tal im schatten des monte talk als
idealen platz für einen stausee aus der
wichtiger teil eines umfassenden
wasserkraft konzeptes werden soll
die schlucht war ein attraktiver
standort weil sie sehr eng ist so dass
man sehr viel wasser mit einer
verhältnismäßig kleinen mauer aufstehen
konnte es ist quasi nur ein steinwurf
von einer seite der schlucht zur anderen
und hier steht sie bis heute die valiant
staumauer
[Musik]
eine bogen staumauer ist eine klassische
dann form sie ist stabil und hält dem
druck der wassermassen dahinter stand
sie sollte ein sechs kilometer langes
reservoir auf sturm
das sind enorme wassermassen wie gegen
so einen daumen drücken aber wenn er wie
ein bogen geformt ist und aus geeignete
material besteht ist der enorm stabil
und man braucht weniger baumaterial um
dem druck standzuhalten
das clevere ist dass die kräfte durch
die konstruktion in die felswände zu
beiden seiten abgeleitet werden
die bauarbeiten beginnen
1957 mit über 400 arbeitern aus der
umgebung die staumauer ist das herzstück
eines ambitionierten wasserkraft
netzwerkes das sich über die region
erstreckt sie ist darauf ausgelegt
169 millionen kubikmeter wasser
aufzustauen über 60 kilometer lange
tunnel sollen so kraftwerke mit wasser
und damit norditalien städte und
fabriken mit dringend benötigten strom
versorgt werden
drei jahre dauern die bauarbeiten bis
der charakteristisch gekrümmte dann
fertiggestellt wusste
ein so großer eindrucksvoller bau in
dieser landschaft zur damaligen zeit
das ist schon ein meisterwerk der
ingenieurskunst
im februar 1960 wird der stau sie
erstmals mit wasser gefüllt der moment
der wahrheit ist gekommen
wenn man einen stausee befüllt ort sich
sehr viel gewicht auf sehr viel druck
der auf den planken lastet gleichzeitig
fließt wasser in gebiete in denen vorher
keines war diese zwei faktoren haben
großen einfluss darauf wie sich die
flutung auswirkt
neun monate lang hält der dann den
wasserspiegel bei gut 600 metern er ist
ein herzstück der hydro elektrizitäts
industrie die rund 85 prozent des
landesweiten stroms liefert doch dann
wird ein zwei kilometer langer riss
entlang eines hans des monte top
entdeckt am vierten november 1960 kommt
es zu einem erdrutsch
700.000 kubikmeter fels und wir stein
gleiten in das reservat nur rund 600
meter von der staumauer entfernt der
spiegel steigt dramatisch an und das
wasser droht die staumauer zu
überströmen
[Musik]
wenn man genug spielraum lässt ist es
nicht unbedingt problematisch wenn etwas
gestein in den see gerutscht das ist
kontrollierbar
als erste reaktion wird sofort der
wasserspiegel gesenkt um den druck auf
die umliegenden hänge zu verringern doch
dann entscheiden die ingenieure den
wasserpegel wieder zu erhöhen
[Musik]
wenn man einen löffel mehrmals hin und
her biegt gibt er irgendwann nach und
bricht in dem sie den wasserspiegel im
stausee erhöhten und absenkten
veränderten sie ständig den druck auf
das gelände
zwischen 1961 und 1963 wird er sie
mehrmals gefüllt und wieder entleert um
die gefahr von weiteren erdrutschen zu
verringern
[Musik]
drei jahre lang geht alles gut der
stausee versorgt mehrere
wasserkraftwerke die die so dringend
benötigte elektrizität für norditalien
städte erzeugen können
im april 1963 scheint den ingenieuren
die schlucht stabil genug zu sein sie
füllen das reservoir auf seine höchst
kapazität auf einen wasserspiegel von
über 700 metern
[Musik]
ingenieure dürfen niemals vergessen die
natürliche umgebung und geologie rund um
ihr bauwerk in ihre pläne mit
einzubeziehen
wenn sie das nicht tun könnte sie das
fürchterlich teuer zu stehen kommen
[Musik]
schon bald folgt die katastrophe am 9
oktober
1963 brechen und 22 uhr 39 über 260
millionen kubikmeter gestein vom montag
ab und rauschen in die tiefe
das ist fast das doppelte des
bauvolumens des sees
es war nicht nur die masse an gestein
gehen das reservoir rutschte sondern
auch die enorme geschwindigkeit
in nur 45 sekunden stürzte der halbe
berghang ins wasser
dadurch entstanden enorme wellen das ist
wie in einer badewanne an einer seite
ist die wand an der anderen der wannen
wand springt man in die wanne schlagen
wellen in beide richtungen eine welle
trifft die wand und zurückgeworfen genau
das geschah in einem teil des tals und
eine schwappt über den rand das ist wie
eine art tsunami
25 millionen kubikmeter wasser bilden
eine monströse flutwelle
250 meter hoch sie schießt das tal
hinunter und der ort lang ohne liegt
direkt in ihrem weg
die wassermassen die durch diese enge
schlucht rasten erzeugt eine druckwelle
nach einer explosion
sie kam vor dem wasser im dorf an und
führte zu den ersten schäden gleich
danach kam dann diese wand aus wasser
mit steinen trümmern und bäumen drin wie
flüssiges schmirgelpapier hat sie den
ort einfach weggewischt
kaum vier minuten nach beginn des
erdrutsches hat die flutwelle den
großteil der stadt dem erdboden
gleichgemacht es ist eine der
schlimmsten von menschen verursachten
umweltkatastrophen in der geschichte
mindestens
1900 menschen kommen ums leben
die tragische ironie ist dass die dörfer
unterhalb der staumauer durch die wucht
der wassermassen quasi vollständig
zerstört wurden die staumauer selbst
aber unbeschädigt blieb das zeigt wohl
wie solide sie geplant und gebaut war
nur eben am falschen ort
preis
das erfüllt sich mit schutt und geröll
und die gewaltige marion staumauer wird
aufgegeben
[Musik]
heute steht sie immer noch da verlassen
in den bergen an vielen stellen sind
noch heute zeugnisse der katastrophe zu
sehen es ist eine ständige mahnung die
naturgewalten niemals zu unterschätzen
aus ingenieur sicht hätte die bayern
staumauer einer der berühmtesten dämme
der geschichte werden sollen stattdessen
ist sie einer der berüchtigsten
es ist eine furchtbare tragödie aber aus
tragödien lernen wir wie die natur
reagieren kann sodass wir künftige
unglücke hoffentlich verhindern könnte
[Musik]
fast 9000 kilometer entfernt auf der
kubanischen isla de la juventud der
insel der jugend steht eine gruppe
ungewöhnliche häuser
die fünf kreisrunden bauwerke sind wie
punkte auf einem würfel angeordnet sie
haben einen durchmesser von jeweils gut
50 metern und stehen auf einem
grasbewachsenen grundstück von mehr als
350.000 quadratmetern
wenn man von einem flugzeug aus auf die
insel hinab sieht fragt man sich sind
diese fünf gelben runden gebäude eine
art bienenstock in industriellen
ausmaßen wie ein herkömmliches kraftwerk
sieht die anlage auch nicht aus also was
ist das
die vier äußeren gebäude sind je 30
meter hoch und haben sechs etagen
theoretisch aber
innen gibt es gar keine etagen nur leere
durch 465 rechteckige öffnung umfeld
nicht ins nasskalte trostlose innere
die anlage hatte einen ziemlich miesen
ruf unter den leuten im ort und die
bedingungen darin waren einfach grausam
in der mitte hier des gebäudes steht ein
kleiner turm wie eine art leuchtturm
sieht er aus
wenn man da rein geht fällt einem sofort
auf dass es keine geraden gänge oder
ecken und winkel gibt alles ist rund so
dass man ständig beobachtet werden kann
es gibt nichts wo man sich verstecken
könnte und das ist absicht
was spielte sich in diesen seltsamen
leeren gebäuden auf dieser entlegenen
insel ab und warum sind sie verlassen
in den 1920 er jahren erlebt kuba eine
phase der rezession und schlimmer
politischer korruption
der kubanische präsident gerardo matador
hat ein umfangreiches öffentliches
bauprogramm angeordnet um das land zu
modernisieren
er will um jeden preis an der macht
bleiben und die absolute kontrolle über
seine politischen gegner erhalten nicht
nur physisch sondern auch psychologisch
dazu sollen unter anderem dieser
ungewöhnliche gebäude komplett denen das
präsidium modell europas vorzeige
gefängnis
es wurde von einem kubanischen diktator
erdacht und entwickelt der orientierte
sich dabei an einem sozialreformer des
achtzehnten jahrhunderts der davon
überzeugt war dass man menschliches
verhalten durch überwachung verändern
kann es
ist ein konzept des englischen
philosophen und gefängnis reformers
jeremy bentham das sogenannte panoptikum
so sollen die gefangenen resozialisiert
werden durch ständige beobachtung das
ist die funktion des wachturms in der
mitte er ist das schlüsselelement des
ganzen aufbaus
[Musik]
der wachturm ist in der mitte und um ihn
herum ein rundes gebäude von 10 der
anlass ist der dass die gefangenen in
ihren zellen nie sicher sein können ob
die wachen gerade sie oder ihren
mithäftlingen eine etage weiter unten
beobachten also müssen sie sich die
ganze zeit gut benehmen
auf mich wirkt der aufbau dieses
gefängnisses wirklich beklemmt dieser
wartung von dem aus theoretisch
jederzeit alle zellen beobachtet werden
können das hat schon was von big brother
es könnte aus orwells 1984 stammt
die bauarbeiten beginnen 1926 sie werden
von gefängnisinsassen ausgeführt sobald
ein gebäude fertiggestellt ist wird es
bezogen
präsident much ado hat es mehr auf
kontrolle als auf resozialisierung
abgesehen aber der aufbau verbreitet
nicht nur angst und paranoia unter den
häftlingen sondern auch statische
vorteile
das konzept der ständigen überwachung
der gefangenen führte zu einem
interessanten baulichen vorteil denn die
kreisförmige außenwand machte die
konstruktion in sich so stabil dass man
keine zwischen der 1000 einziehen musste
anfang der 1930 er jahre ist das
präsidium modelo fertig mit 465 cent pro
gebäude ist der komplex auf bis zu 2500
häftlinge ausgelegt
die zellen sind alle nach innen auf dem
zentralen wachturm hin ausgerichtet und
sie haben keine türen
die architektur des gebäudes sollte die
absolute kontrolle und überwachung der
insassen ermöglichen
beide male war andre aufsicht lichte
hier als wache die insassen
hombach turm aus kontrollierten wir die
gefangenen werde es ärger sagten wir
ruhe da
und schon war es still der wachturm half
ordnung zu halten
unsichtbar für die gefangenen die selbst
nie wissen ob und wann sie beobachtet
werden kommen die wachen über einen 30
meter langen unterirdischen korridor in
den turm von ihren posten in dessen
oberen teil können sie die gefangenen
ungesehen durch enge schlitze beobachten
man steht ständig unter beobachtung
nicht nur durch die wächter im turm
sondern auch durch mitgefangene deren
zellen nur wenige meter entfernt sind
man hat keinerlei privatsphäre das muss
paranoia erzeugt haben die großen
freiflächen in den gebäuden machen die
überwachung einfach außerdem halten die
gefangenen sich zunehmend gegenseitig in
schach
selbst beim essen im zentral gelegenen
speisesaal werden die häftlinge von den
wachen ständig beobachtet und sie müssen
die ganze zeit schweigen
wenn man aus seiner zelle in der man
unter ständiger beobachtung steht zum
essen geht sollte man meinen man könne
sich mal mit seinen mitinsassen
unterhalten aber nichts da man ging in
den sogenannten saal der 3000 stellen
der so hieß weil man nicht sprechen
durfte
wir drücken dass sein muss man wird den
ganzen tag in seiner zelle beobachtet
und dann darf man nicht einmal beim
essen sprechen
tatsächlich bringt das hoch moderne
design das eigentlich zur
resozialisierung von häftlingen dienen
soll den gefängnis einen furchtbaren ruf
ein und angeblich sind es nicht nur
aufmerksame wächter die die insassen
unter kontrolle halten
[Musik]
es kursieren zahlreiche legenden über
das gefängnis und eine davon besagt in
den teichen und wasser gelben rund um
das gelände hätte es krokodile gegeben
als es erbaut wurde lebten hier
krokodile wenn ein gefangener flow wurde
er eben von ihnen gestoppt das war's
dann mit dem leben in freiheit
präsident mit shadow kann sich nicht an
der macht halten das gefängnis hingegen
bleibt bis 1967 in betrieb
1953 betritt seien heute berühmteste
insasse die haftanstalt der
kommunistische revolutionsführer fidel
castro setz dir zwei jahre lang für den
versuchten sturz des brutalen diktators
fulgencio batista 1 an seiner seite ist
sein bruder raúl
als politische häftlinge werden die
beiden relativ human behandelt aber
fidel castro erfährt aus nächster nähe
wie psychologisch wirkungsvoll der
aufbau des gefängnisses ist und erkennt
sein potenzial kontrolle auszuüben
diese erfahrung nutzt er als er 1959
battista tatsächlich stürzt und setzt
die macht in kuba ergreift
als er an die macht kam ließ er den
komplex nicht etwa zerstören nein er
schickte seine politischen gegner
dorthin das ist krass
acht jahre lang nutzt castro das
präsidium modell um seine feinde aus dem
weg zu räumen
aber die politischen gefangenen stellen
ein ernsthaftes sicherheitsrisiko dar
während der durch die cia gestützten
invasion in der schweinebucht 1961
gibt es den plan die haftanstalt zu
zerstören
sie wollten die gebäude in die luft
jagen in dem die sprengladungen in den
wächter tonnen platzieren
wenn man bedenkt wie groß diese bauten
sind und wie stabil auf grund ihrer
bauweise würde ich annehmen das ist
ziemlich schwierig gewesen wäre sie
tatsächlich zu zerstören
dynamit kann das präsidium oder
vielleicht nicht ohne weiteres klein
kriegen aber castro kann es die
haftanstalt ist auf rund 2.500 gefangene
ausgelegt er lässt dreimal so viele hier
einfachen
ursprünglich waren vielleicht bis zu
3000 häftlinge vorgesehen und jetzt
saßen dort sechs bis achttausend
ausschreitungen waren an der
tagesordnung dazu prügeleien und
unhygienische bedingungen es war die
hölle die extreme überbelegung und deren
folgen sollen sich rächen der widerstand
unter den gefangenen wächst um für
castro wird die haftanstalt immer mehr
zum sicherheitsrisiko
1967 wird cobas vorzeige gefängnis
schließlich geschlossen und castros
gegner werden in andere haftanstalten
verlegt
der betrieb wurde eingestellt es war
auch etwas baufällig aber vor allem
hatte sich das politische klima geändert
und es war nicht mehr von nutzen
die gebäude sind so einzigartig in
aufbau und funktion dass es praktisch
unmöglich ist sie um zu funktionieren
nach rund 40 jahren unterdrückung und
verfolgungswahn in ihrem inneren werden
sie einfach sich selbst überlassen
heute sind die gewaltigen und orden des
präsidium modell nur noch verfallende
hüllen und ein mahnmal für
menschenrechtsverletzungen trotz
eigentlich guter absichten bis zum
frühjahr 2018 ist raúl castro zehn jahre
lang präsident kubas während an den
wänden der krankenstation noch immer dem
berühmtesten insassen des modell
gefängnisses gewürdigt wird seinem
bruder fidel nie zuvor und nie wieder
wurde jeremy bentham muss panoptikum
konzept so direkt umgesetzt wie hier
heute ist das gefängnis ein museum und
forschungszentrum das ist gut so denn
historisch betrachtet war es ein
innovativer ansatz zur
gesellschaftlichen reformen alles drehte
sich um überwachung damit war man
derzeit damals weit voraus
[Musik]
in den usa im bundestaat kalifornien
verbirgt sich in karger landschaft diese
rätselhafte anlage hoch über los angeles
findet sich ein abgesperrter
straßenabschnitt gut 250 meter dies
seien gabriel mountains ihn auf er führt
zu einem mehr als sechs meter hohen
steinernen bogen der in einen berghang
eingelassen ist
was hat es mit diesem eingang auf sich
und wohin führt er
bei diesen eingängen amberg fragt man
sich wozu sich jemand die mühe gemacht
hat diese riesigen tunnel zu bauen
man rechnet mit eisenbahnschienen oder
einer straße die dort herauskommt aber
da ist nichts das ist schon mysteriös
das licht am ende des dunklen tunnels
zeigt dass er durch den ganzen berg
verläuft
wenn man davor steht ist der tunnel an
sich schon beeindruckend und es war ganz
sicher nicht leicht ihn zu bauen aber es
steckt noch sehr viel mehr dahinter als
man auf den ersten blick denkt
warum hat sich jemand die mühe gemacht
diesen riesigen tunnel anzulegen um ihn
anschließend sich selbst zu überlassen
[Musik]
in den 1950 er jahren hat der kalte
krieg die usa fest im griff die
amerikaner fürchten nicht nur eine
invasion sondern vor allem einen
atomangriff der sowjetunion
als zahlreiche luft und raumfahrt
einrichtungen machen die stadt zu einem
wahrscheinlichen ziel die amerikanischen
frühwarnsysteme können sowjetische
bomber einige stunden vor dem einschlag
der bomben ausmachen aber wie sollen die
behörden innerhalb dieser kurzen zeit
rund zwei millionen einwohner in
sicherheit bringen
sie fragten sich wie sie evakuieren
könnten
wenn sie so wie jetzt wirklich einen
atomschlag auf los angeles ausführung
brauchen die behörden einen rettungsplan
für die einwohner stadt
um aus los angeles herauszukommen muss
man durch die berge das bedeutet
entweder den verschlungenen straßen über
die pässe zu folgen oder einen tunnel
mitten durch zu bauen
also wird eine 40 kilometer lange
rettungs route entwickelt über sie
sollen die einwohner so schnell wie
möglich durch mehrere tunnel in die
sichere morawe wüste fliehen
diese route ist die shoemaker canyon
road auch carmageddon highway genannt
in armageddon highway lars die annahme
zugrunde dass die gesamte bevölkerung
von l per auto aus der stadt fliehen
würde um der vernichtung zu entgehen
das war damals kulturell tief verankert
diese angst dass der feind die
technologie hat um uns anzugreifen und
wir uns irgendwie davor schützen müssen
nach ihrer fertigstellung sollen diese
kostspieligen tonne einen
lebensrettenden fluchtweg mitten durch
die berge bieten
während des kalten kriegs in den 50ern
hatten alle angst vor einem atomkrieg
also ließ die us-regierung einen berg
durch tunnel damit sich die bevölkerung
von los angeles im falle eines atom
schlags retten konnte
eine sowjetische atom waffen die im
luftraum über elly detonierte hätte mehr
menschen töten können als in hiroshima
und nagasaki zusammen starben
einen tunnel durch massives gestein zu
treiben ist im besten falle schwierig in
den klimatisch unbeständigen sergey brin
mountains sind die herausforderungen
noch größer im sommer herrscht hitze im
winter gibt es lawinen und ständig
drohen erdrutsche
die arbeiten beginnen 1956 um
sicherzustellen dass der 300 meter lange
tunnel in dieser anspruchsvollen
umgebung stabil bleibt wird er an
kritischen stellen mit stahlträgern und
beton vom stein verstärkt
man sollte meinen dass für ein so
wichtiges projekt auf profis gesetzt
wurde aber stattdessen liessen sie
häftlinge aus einem nahegelegenen
gefängnis in die berge gehen und die
straße bauen die waren weder motiviert
noch wussten sie wie das geht mit
den ungelernten arbeitern die sich
abmühen den massiven fels zu bezwingen
kommt der bau des zweispurigen rettungs
highways nur langsam voran erst 1961
wird der erste teil fertiggestellt fünf
jahre nach baubeginn
dass man bereit war sich den weg mitten
durch diese berge zu sprengen zeigt wie
panisch man damals versuchte den
einwohnern einer us großstadt einen
fluchtweg in sichere gefilde zu
verschaffen
man sieht förmlich vor sich wie
verängstigte menschen versuchen eine
atomexplosion in einer metropolregion zu
entgehen nur langsam macht die
fluchtroute quer durch die berge
fortschritte und der plan hat eine
entscheidende schwachstelle
der bau ging nur sehr schleppend voran
und bei den behörden kamen zweifel auf
ob die rettungs route nicht vor allem
gigantische staus auslösen würde im
ernstfall wäre es wohl praktisch
unmöglich die straße zu erreichen weil
der verkehr zusammenbricht
bei den berüchtigten staus auf den
highways von los angeles ist die
vorstellung aller einwohner hätten sich
über den amador heiko retten können
total lächerlich man braucht sich nur
anzuschauen was heutzutage auf den
highways von allein los ist
und mit aufkommen schneller
interkontinentalraketen schrumpft die
vorwarnzeit auf 15 bis 20 minuten eine
flucht vor den sowjetischen atomwaffen
wird damit schlicht unmöglich
die evakuierungspläne durch den chemiker
canyon sind hinfällig
die vorlaufzeit liegt bei fast null das
macht es im grunde unmöglich größere
ballungszentren zu evakuieren ende der
1960 er jahre gegen ihnen wohl auf dass
das ganze nichts als eine gigantische
geldverschwendung war
1969 13 jahre nach beginn der
bauarbeiten
setzen die behörden dem fluchtrouten
projekt schließlich ein ende
von der geplanten 40 kilometer langen
abkürzung durch den shoemaker canyon
sind bis dahin lediglich sieben
kilometer straße und zwei tunnel ins
nirgendwo umgesetzt worden die straße
und die tunnel in den hängen des schumi
kann ihren gibt es bis heute aber kaum
jemand kommt je her und so sind sie ein
weitgehend unbeachtetes mahnmal der
angst der einwohner von los angeles im
kalten krieg
die augenfälligsten überreste sind die
tunnel es ist schon bemerkenswert was
die angst im kalten krieg die menschen
getrieben hat
[Musik]
tausende kilometer entfernt auf der
anderen seite des atlantiks an der
südküste englands liegt der küstenort
model storm
[Musik]
in den raum gewässern des ärmelkanals
kann man ein seltsames gut 60 meter
langes und knapp zehn meter breites
gebilde sehen halb unter wasser
[Musik]
könnte man es bei einem
morgenspaziergang zum beispiel leicht
für einen gesunkenen frachtkahn oder
sowas halten was song bodies und weg
tatsächlich aber ist es
geschichtsträchtiger als man je erahnen
wird
[Musik]
bei apple wird der große 6000 tonnen
blog beton weiter freigelegt
das unscheinbare aus enttäuscht über
seine bautechnische und historische
bedeutung hinweg
damals waren sich die ingenieure
bestimmt unsicher ob sie damit nicht ein
zu großes risiko eingehen aber wie genau
spielte diese simple wirkende
konstruktion eine schlüsselrolle bei der
größte landungsoperation aller zeiten
warum ist sie hier und warum wurde sie
sich selbst überlassen
1944 wird im süden englands eine
streitmacht von enormen ausmaßen
mobilgemacht weit über eine million
soldaten dazu 12.000 flugzeuge und eine
armada von fast 7000 seefahrzeugen am d
day wollen die alliierten von hier aus
in der normandie lampen die
herausforderungen sind enorm hitler hat
den atlantik weil errichten lassen der
eine landung verhindern soll und die
riesige invasions macht an land zu
bringen ist nicht das einzige problem
den briten und amerikanern war klar dass
es sehr schwierig werden würde die
versorgung der soldaten sicher zu
stellen damit sie weiter kämpfen konnten
nachdem man sie am strand abgesetzt
hatte
die alliierten entwickeln einen
ehrgeizigen plan um die weitere
versorgung der truppen sicher zu stellen
die alliierten kombinierten technologien
aus dem hoch- und tiefbau dem militär
bauwesen und der werkstoffkunde zu etwas
völlig neuem einen kompletten hafen der
100 kilometer weit verlegt werden konnte
unter dem code namen operation x ray
wird ein wichtiger teil der schwimmenden
helfen entwickelt der fenix
wellenbrecher der felix wellenbrecher
ist nur ein teil eines unglaublich
komplexen aber gleichzeitig genial
einfachen konzept nämlich vorgefertigte
schwimmende häfen für die landung an die
strände der normandie zu transportieren
die wellenbrecher sollen den künstlichen
hilfen wichtigen schutz vor schwerer see
bieten
aber stahl ist während des krieges knapp
also setzten die ingenieure auf leichter
verfügbares material
die idee der schwimmenden betonblöcke
ist nicht nur beton schiffe wurden seit
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts gebaut
aber
jetzt wurden sie dafür genutzt einen
hafen so groß wie ein moderner
internationaler fährhafen zu bauen
jeder der betonblöcke ist rund 20 meter
hoch in einer kette miteinander
verbunden sollen sie als schutzbarriere
für die schwimmenden mal riefen dienen
die klinik senkt kess und sollten als
wellenbrecher und äußere begrenzung des
hafens demo so dass man ruhigeres wasser
hatte und die versorgungsgüter fahrzeuge
und truppen an landen konnte die man
nach dem d day brauchte
der sinkkasten besteht aus einer
verstärkten betonhülle mit neun
hohlkammern die auftrieb erzeugen
übersee ventile kann jede kammer
geflutet und der kasten so auf einer
bestimmten position abgesenkt werden
der felix senkt kasten steht ziemlich
weit oben bei den genialen baulichen
entwicklungen während des zweiten
weltkriegs die ingenieure haben eine
sehr effektive und clevere lösung für
ihre aufgabe gefunden
der bau der senke ssten beginnt ende
1943 die arbeiter sollen 212 stück
herstellen sie haben dafür rund sechs
monate zeit
an zwölf verschiedenen britischen küsten
ordnung sind bis zu 45.000 arbeiter
unter absoluter geheimhaltung am werk
insgesamt verbauen sie rund
230.000 kubikmeter beton und über 30.000
tonnen stahl
viele männer waren im krieg also
organisierte man sich ungelernte
arbeiter es dauerte nicht solange ihnen
beizubringen wie man stahl bearbeitet
und beton gießt denn das ist weder
hochtechnisch noch besonders kompliziert
ein projekt dieser größenordnung können
die alliierten nicht vollständig vor den
deutschen verheimlichen aber hitler darf
keinesfalls erfahren für wann und wo die
feindliche invasion geplant ist um das
sicherzustellen machen sich die militärs
die funktionsweise der wellenbrecher
zunutze
[Applaus]
damit die deutschen nicht vorgewarnt
würden wurden die phoenix wellenbrecher
direkt nach ihrer ankunft am sammelpunkt
an der südküste versenkt so dass sie
nicht mehr zu sehen war bevor es rüber
nach frankreich ging sollte das wasser
dann wieder abgepumpt werden damit sie
auftrieb bekamen und schwamm in
rund sechs monaten werden 212 phoenix
sinkkästen gebaut und viele von ihnen in
vorbereitung auf den die idee im
ärmelkanal versenkt wenn die zeit
gekommen ist sollen sie sich getreu
ihres namens wie ein phönix erheben und
ihre rolle bei der invasion ausfüllen
natürlich hoffte man dass sie wirklich
tun was sie sollen nämlich unverrückbar
den meeresströmungen trotzen
am 6 juni 1944 erklären schließlich
160.000 alliierte soldaten den
ärmelkanal
innerhalb von 24 stunden sichern sie die
brückenköpfe nun müssen schnell genug
nachschub waffen und versorgungsgütern
angelandet werden die alliierten lassen
die phoenix senkt gästen wieder
aufsteigen und schleppen sie an die
strände der normandie um dort die
schwimmenden hafen anzulegen die dieses
enorme unterfangen möglich machen sollen
die phoenix senkt gästen hat eine sechs
mann besatzung
was für eine vorstellung auf einem
schwimmenden betonklotz stationär zu
sein sie wurden von schleppern gezogen
und an bord gab es eine kleine kabine
ein rettungsboot für den fall dass etwas
schief ging und auch flugabwehrgeschütze
falls sie unter beschuss gerät
bei einer geschwindigkeit von drei
knoten dauert es 30 stunden
146 dieser riesigen beton sinkkästen zu
den stränden zu bringen
an ihrer jeweiligen position versenkt
bilden sie nun ein rund drei kilometer
langes wellenbrecher system für die
künstlichen hafenanlagen
diese betonklötze sind nicht besonders
beeindruckend aber wie diese senkt
hessen genutzt wurden um material männer
und ausrüstung an die französischen
strände zu bekommen das war sehr
bedeutsam
der hafen ist rund zwei quadratkilometer
groß und wird komplett von den
künstlichen riff aus phoenix
wellenbrechern geschützt sie sorgen für
ruhige see so dass schiffe bei ebbe und
flut sicher an den schwimmenden pierce
anlegen können
die deutschen sind erfolgreich
überrumpelt worden auch weil sie die
versenkten phoenix sinkkästen nicht
entdeckt haben
eigentlich sollte er drei monate in
betrieb sein aber der mulberry hafen am
golf beach wird auch zehn monate später
noch genutzt auch dank der phoenix sind
kasten schaffen es die alliierten
unglaubliche zweieinhalb millionen mann
eine halbe million fahrzeuge und 4
millionen tonnen versorgungsgüter an
land zu bringen
für die beteiligten ingenieure waren die
mulberry häfen ein wahnsinniger erfolg
die landung in der normandie gilt als
eines der bedeutendsten ereignisse der
geschichte und die phoenix wellenbrecher
haben daran großen anteil
aber nicht alle senkrechten
funktionieren wie geplant viele schaffen
es nicht ans ziel
trotz aller bemühungen gelingt es den
ingenieuren nicht diesen sinkkasten vor
der küste von mittels dom zu bewegen
das problem war dass der meeresgrund in
manchen gebieten sehr schlammig war
trotz aller mühe der senkt kosten voll
mittels dauern war einfach nicht zum
schwimmen zu bringen war
unfähig sich aus dem tiefen sand vor der
englischen küste zu erheben liegt er bis
heute verlassen hier
diese so simpel erscheinenden
betonkästen spielten eine wichtige rolle
bei der erfolgreichen landung der
alliierten in der normandie und damit
bei der beendigung des zweiten
weltkriegs
[Musik]
die geschichte des phoenix senkt kastens
for little stone ist auf eine weise eine
geschichte des scheiterns
denn er hat es nicht nach frankreich
geschafft aber wenn man ihn heute zum
schwimmen kriegen würde könnte er noch
immer seine funktion erfüllen und das
zeigt dass er clever entworfen und
solide geplant
[Musik]
heute sind sie verlassen aber sie
gehörten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
diese verfallenden konstruktionen sind
ein echo der vergangenheit sie erzählen
von krieg und schrecken aber auch von
entdeckergeist und
fortschritt
[Musik]